as experienced s franchise director
Kevin grard revealed in an interview
with mme one of the torture scenes in
sawx was apparently so brutal that it
got first assistant editor Steve forer
in trouble with his neighbors and local
law enforcement while editing audio for
the eyeball trap scene neighbors of
Steve forer presumably unaware of what
he did for a living became concerned
that the mild mannered artist was
torturing someone in his home as a home
video camera reportedly captured LPD
officers responded to the disturbance
call and knocked on his door at which
point a startled forer answered likely
hoping that his excuse of working on a
movie wasn't one that real serial
killers employ according to forer the
cops told him that the neighbors had
rang them up accusing him of violently
torturing a real person after explaining
that he was simply cutting together a
scene for a horror film forer even
invited the officers in to watch the
sequence for themselves the realization
was enough to send the cops into a fit
of laughter before they politely
declined the invitation and left forer
to his bloody workload